der winter war zurück am wochenende in
weiten teilen deutschlands mit schnee
und eisigem wind wie hier in winterberg
im sauerland nutzten viele am samstag
nochmal den schnee für ski und rodel
spaß oder einfach nur für einen
winterspaziergang am flughafen frankfurt
bedeutete das kalte wetter dann am
sonntag eher mehrarbeit die enteiser
hatten gut zu tun um die flugzeuge
startklar zu machen
dennoch mussten nach angaben des
flughafenbetreibers fraport 150 flüge
ausfallen
in winterberg richteten sich am samstag
schon erste hoffnungen auf den frühling
es ist das letzte aufbauen bevor es
jetzt richtig frühling wird und das ist
klasse bei vorne und schon drauf ich bin
da dürfte aber noch etwas geduld nötig
sein denn die meteorologen sagen für die
nächsten tage weiter minusgrade voraus